patricia hier ist ja viele buchstaben
viel papier und das ist sozusagen die
kurzfassung des koalitionsvertrages und
das ist ihr erster blick da rein also
das soll die nächsten vier jahre
bestimmen diese worte die hier auf
diesem papier verewigt wurde an den
stundenlang geschraubt wurde zuletzt bis
tief in die nacht hinein olaf scholz
erst viertel nach zwei nach hause
gegangen in der vergangenen nacht und
das ein ganz wichtiger satz an dem
werden wir die ampel messen wir machen
politik die das leben der menschen ganz
konkret besser macht das also ein
wesentliches ziel der ampel regierung
für die nächsten vier jahre und jetzt
wollen wir natürlich wissen das ist ja
gutes ziel aber wie will man das sinn
machen und das ist dann auf den
folgenden seiten auch aufgeführt und
etwas konkreter gefasst zum beispiel
soll es zur modernisierung des
sozialstaates ein neues bürgergeld geben
dass punkt eins und dann ganz
entscheidend der mindestlohn das war ja
die zentrale
wahlkampfforderung das
wahlkampfversprechen von olaf scholz im
spd-wahlkampf der mindestlohn von 12
euro der kommt und da sagt die ampel
jetzt in ihrem papier ganz konkret das
ist eine gehaltserhöhung für zehn
millionen menschen das also ganz wichtig
und zentral in diesem ampel
koalitionsvertrag dann ganz wichtig das
was drunter steht für alle jungen
menschen für alle jugendlichen in
deutschland ist kommt das wahlrecht ab
16 bundesweit das will die ampel also
dann da braucht es die zustimmung auch
in den ländern im bundesrat aber das
will die ampel tatsächlich durchboxen in
den nächsten vier jahren die apple
verspricht auch eine
ausbildungsplatzgarantie für alle jungen
menschen eine reform des bafögs also
dass ganz gezielt die ansprache von fdp
und grüne die ja so viele junge wähler
hatten bei dieser bundestagswahl an alle
jugendlichen und jungen deutschen wir
gehen weiter und da sehen wir schon
bezahlbare wohnen ist hier die
überschrift das ist also ein ganz
wichtiger punkt für die ampel und das
fast sie auch relativ konkret wie will
man das denn schaffen also nicht nur das
höhere ziel sondern zuletzt sind zwar
ganz oft solche versprechen versprechen
geblieben konnten dann nicht umgesetzt
es werden nun doch nennt sich die ampel
eine ganz konkrete zahl
400.000 neue wohnungen will man bauen
und zwar in jedem jahr jährlich das ist
das ziel hier werden wir die ampel daran
messen dürfen nach vier jahren regierung
darunter sollen 100.000 also von diesen
400.000 neuen wohnungen 100.000 auch
öffentlich gefördert sei die mietpreis
bremse gleich darunter die soll
verlängert werden also bezahlbares
wohnen ein ganz wichtiger punkt wird
hier unten geht es dann um den punkt
inflation der die hohen energiepreise
ganz großes thema hier bei bild ganz
großes thema für sie in ihrem alltag in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten da
sagt die ampel noch einmal nach da haben
wir ja schon den ersten beschluss
gefasst nämlich den heizkostenzuschuss
für einkommensschwache familien das ganz
wichtige lebensnahe themen die man hier
vorangestellt hat besonders geheiratet
hat in diesem koalitionsvertrag
klimaschutz und industrie klar wichtiger
punkt nicht nur aber vor allen dingen
natürlich für die grünen in diesem
koalitionsvertrag und da setzt man auf
massiven ausbau der erneuerbaren energie
also massiv ist das entscheidende wort
will man netze windräder die
infrastruktur ausbauen und man will
dafür gleichzeitig sorgen daran werden
wir die ampel messen dass energie
bezahlbar bleibt bei uns im land und
ganz wichtig der letzte satz hier unten
dieser unser anspruch ist dass die
klimafreundliche lösung immer die
einfachere ist also klimaschutz soll
keine last sein in den nächsten vier
jahren rente das wichtigste
wahlkampfthema für die meisten deutschen
und auch deswegen ein zentraler punkt
hier im koalitionsvertrag rente ganz
klar sagt die ampel die renten werden
nicht gekürzt das rentenniveau bleibt
und auch das renteneintrittsalter wird
nicht erhöht dass das versprechen der
ampel regierung und dann schauen wir
noch einmal ganz wichtig auf das thema
familie und kinder da wird die ampel so
wie es auch schon in dem ersten papier
dem sondierungs papier der ampel stand
eine kindergrundsicherung einführen
zentraler punkt im koalitionsvertrag und
dann dieses versprechen und auch das
müssen sich ganz genau anschauen
wird ein jahrzehnt der bildungschancen
gestartet die ampel startet ein
jahrzehnt der bildungschancen mit dem
ganz konkreten versprechen wir lassen es
nicht mehr zu dass unsere kita kinder in
marode schulen und kitas gehen wir
lassen das nicht mehr zu einsatz an dem
sich die ampel wird messen lassen in den
nächsten vier jahren letztes versprechen
hier in dieser kurzfassung des
koalitionsvertrags betrifft den bereich
gesundheit und pflege da ist unter
anderem die rede von einer einrichtung
eines corona krisenstabs möglicherweise
das etwas für karl lauterbach in corona
krisenstab wird eingerichtet um die
aktuelle corona krise bestmöglich zu
wuppen und dann sollen ganz konkret
altenpflegerinnen und altenpfleger
besser belohnt besser entlohnt werden
hier stets wichtige arbeit soll
angemessen bezahlt werden deshalb
verbessern wir die löhne in der
altenpflege also ganz konkret auch das
ein versprechen an alle alten pfleger
und pflegerinnen in deutschland genügend
stoff zur diskussion mit ihr patricia
und paul ronzheimer
ja vielen herzlichen dank dass also die
ersten seiten des koalitionsvertrag um
15 uhr gibt es eine pressekonferenz mit
weiteren details bei mir paul ronzheimer
unser bild vize das ist auch in den
vergangenen tagen beobachtet jetzt sehen
wir dass zum ersten mal jetzt nachdem
sondierungs papier das ja schon recht
konkret war sehen wir schwarz auf weiß
wohnen mindestlohn bildung das sind die
großen themen der ampel überrascht da
irgendetwas was mich überrascht ist wie
klar sich die fdp insgesamt durchgesetzt
hat nicht nur thematisch sondern auch
angesichts der ministerien wenn wir uns
anschauen dass die fdp finanzen bekommen
hat verkehr justiz bildung alle
wichtigen zukunftsminister riehen oder
zumindest vier wichtige zukunftsminister
er ihn besetzt dann auch noch finanzen
wo christian lindner immer wird sagen
können nein dafür ist nicht genug geld
da also er sitzt auf der kohle der
künftigen koalition da muss man sagen
respekt fdp was die alles durchgesetzt
haben gleichzeitig die grünen sich aber
auch gut positioniert viele waren jetzt
heute überrascht dass annalena baerbock
es geschafft hat ihr zweites ziel nach
kanzlerin zu werden dann zu
verwirklichen und sie wird
außenministerin ich war nicht überrascht
dass andere in der werbung
außenministerin geworden ist oder wird
das ist etwas was eigentlich in den
verhandlungen von anfang an sie klar
gemacht hat ich will ins ausnahmen das
war eigentlich auch schon in der in dem
wahlkampf ihr ziel das hat man gemerkt
am ende sie wollte sich dann nur noch
rein retten und nicht zu sehr beschädigt
werden als dass die koalition noch
gefährdet werden könnte als
juniorpartnerin ich glaube dass die
grünen die größten probleme bekommen
werden in mit ihrer basis wir dürfen
eines nicht vergessen wir sehen eine
realo linke regierung so will ich es mal
nennen mit eigentlich guten köpfen keine
verrückten die man jetzt auf den ersten
blick sieht in den ministerien
ministerliste aber wenn wir uns
anschauen wie links die fraktionen sind
die grünen die spd werde alles im
bundestag sitzt dann glaube ich werden
die grünen bei ihrem parteitag zu hören
bekommen dass sie nicht genügend
umgesetzt haben was das thema klima
angeht jetzt haben wir gerade die ersten
inhalte aus dem koalitionsvertrag
gesehen paul mein erster eindruck war so
ein bisschen es ist schon ein relativ
vielen punkten zu nämlich konkret
vielleicht konkreter als vergangene
koalitionsverträge in denen sich ja ganz
lange viele seiten immer wieder finden
wo man ganz schnell durchblättern kann
aber hier gibt es konkrete versprechen
ist das gefährlich für die ampel denn
ich habe ja immer wieder gesagt daran
wird sie sich messen lassen müssen das
ist gefährlich und gleichzeitig eine
chance ich glaube wenn man sagen kann
häkchen dran wir haben tatsächlich diese
zahl erreicht dann ist es für die bürger
viel klarer zu sehen hatte diese
regierung erfolgt und wenn es ein
realistisches ziel ist und davon gehe
ich aus dass man sich dort realistische
ziele gesetzt hat 400.000 wohnungen
klingt viel aber eines darf man nicht
vergessen das war das thema insbesondere
der spd im wahlkampf denn wir sehen die
mieten steigerungen für viele menschen
großes problem und das zum thema machen
mit einer klaren zahl für nicht klug
keine klaren zahlen gibt es bei den aus
mehrausgaben für bildung die angekündigt
werden und auch bei den mehrausgaben in
der altenpflege die angekündigt werden
da hat man sich also nicht ganz so weit
aus dem fenster gewagt wie jetzt beim
thema wohnen wir holen jetzt in unser
gespräch peter tiede dazu unser
chefreporter der er bis in die frühen
morgenstunden und auch gleich wieder
heute morgen für uns da ist mit weiteren
einschätzungen jetzt in dieser absolut
heißen phase ist nicht mehr lange hin
nach zwei stunden noch dann wissen wir
alle details aus diesem
koalitionsvertrag peter kannst du schon
einschätzen was uns sonst noch erwartet
gute laune also man wird jetzt sagen wir
haben uns zusammengefunden und das waren
harte verhandlungen das muss man sagen
damit man damit auch für die partei
treten kann und da muss man gut ist knie
blutige nase blaues auge vorzeigen
können und sagen aber guckt mal was wir
alles gewonnen haben und schaut euch mal
die anderen an wie schlimm die aussehen
also die klassische kneipenschlägerei
das ist die geschichte die man hinterher
erzählt ich hatte so ein blaues auge
aber die anderen haben zwei das wird
kommen und dann wird es richtig groß
dann wird die konfettikanone
angeschmissen und die gute laune kommt
aus einem boxen raus das macht man das
ist auch schon intoniert bei tweets von
lars klingbeil dann es hat ja alles
angefangen mit einem tweet der grünen
und der fdp als man die die nation damit
überrascht hat dass man doch schon
relativ schnell an einem abend mal so
eine art vor sondierungen zwischen grün
und gelb an angefangen und jetzt gibt es
111 von
den generälen und zwar von lars
klingbeil der spd-generalsekretär
veröffentlicht mit herrn wissing von der
fdp und den herrn kellner von den grünen
also am anfang war ein 21 11 am ende ist
ein dreier ist wie ein koalitionsvertrag
und ein kabinett das wird man heute
gebühren staatstragend vortrag weil man
ist ja jetzt quasi nur noch diesen
halben piss pott schritt von der
regierung entfernt man hat den
koalitionsvertrag man muss jetzt noch
durch die parteigremien durch
staatstragend und mit stolz wird man das
heute alles vortragen also das wird
jetzt die tonlage ab spätestens 15 uhr
ist ja klar dass man sich jetzt nicht
mehr gegenseitig da weg gerät man will
ja zusammen regieren aber trotzdem du
hast ja jetzt über wochen das ganze
theater da verfolgt dass die ganze
regierungsbildung peter wieviel ja
vielleicht heuchelei oder im besten fall
guter wille ist im spiel denn weiterhin
ist es ja hofreiter muss mit lindner
funktionieren zum beispiel essen muss
mit göring eckardt und lindner usw
funktionieren also das sind ja nicht
bisher die ganz großen freundschaften
gewesen wird das funktionieren
ja was ist auch es ist ja auch keine
freundeskreise also hier gehen ja jetzt
nicht drei parteien die sich richtig
knocke finden weil eben mal so zum
campingurlaub oder zum mangel ausflug
das ist harte arbeit da muss man sich
nicht immer gut verstehen sondern man
muss ein gemeinsames ziel haben man muss
sich eigentlich darüber sein dass man
dem anderen auch mal etwas gönnen können
muss und dass das land das mit
dazugehört und neu war für mich
tatsächlich die art und weise wie
verhandelt worden ist die journalistin
schwierig die haben hier quasi wie
schwangere aus da haben die haben die
hier verhandelt es gab nichts nach außen
man hat bilder vermieden annalena
baerbock hatte zum anfang mal gesagt die
journalisten werden nicht einmal
erfahren was auf dem brötchen ist käse
oder wurst bisschen was haben wir dann
am ende doch erfahren aber so hat man
verhandelt und man hat vor einem
vertrauensvoll miteinander verhandelt
und das war das signal das man aus
senden wollte das hier dass es hier um
vertrauen geht dass man weiß dass es
heikel ist das ein dreierbündnis mit
dieser politischen spreizung wirklich
heikel ist und dass man deswegen auch
schon anders miteinander umgehen muss
von anfang an wenn diese tonlage hält
diese respektvolle tonlage nicht wie in
der groko es ja wirklich teilweise
schrill hergehen dann kann das
tatsächlich der anfang eines neuen
politischen tons in deutschland sein ich
war's doch zu bezweifeln weil jedem
anfang wohnt ein zauber inne aber mit
gehöriger wegstrecke wird es dann auch
manchmal disharmonische aber die art und
weise wie verhandelt worden ist die
tonlage die angeschlagen worden ist das
ist schon etwas anderes das ist der
versuch etwas neues auf den weg zu
stellen und ihr habt gerade angesprochen
mit den passagen aus dem
koalitionsvertrag da stehen ganz ganz
konkrete sachen drin schon in der
kurzfassung und darf also noch mal
gespannt sein auf die längere version da
steht ja dann noch mehr drin da ist es
dann auch noch mal ausgetauscht und das
ist schon wirklich ungewöhnlich und das
zeigt aber auch dass man sich messen
lassen will und dass man ernsthaft
wirklich große projekte angehen will sie
müssen eine mehr politisch vielleicht
nicht gefallen mag auch nicht die mir
selbst das bild eines jeden deutschen
irgendwie entsprechen aber zumindest
haben sie ambitionen die stellen sie
deutlich heraus die werden bezahlen und
untermauert und sie machen sich selbst
messbar und das ist schon etwas da haben
sie die latte bisschen höher gelegt als
die bisher lag in diesem land das ist
angesprochen peter man kann schwer sagen
was sich hinter den kulissen abspielt
darauf wurde dieses mal ganz genau
geachtet dass wirklich nichts nach
draußen dringt es ist uns auch weniger
als zwei stunden hast du irgendwelche
informationen darüber wie alle
beteiligten diese zwei stunden jetzt
verbringen sitzt man da schon hinter den
kulissen stößt an und sagt mensch auf
die abendliche ist die grün geschaltet
es geht los und da wird da jetzt noch so
ein bisschen an irgendetwas
rumgeschraubt
also schampus gibt es wahrscheinlich
erst heute und den auch nur hinter den
kulissen öffentlich angestoßen wird erst
wenn man durch die parteien durch ist
das heißt für die spd und für die grünen
das ist jetzt an die an die basis geht
das dauert jetzt noch ein paar tage bis
man damit durch ist und damit dann auch
der traum von olaf scholz in erfüllung
gehen kann dass er der erste nikolaus
kanzler deutschland wird also in der
nikolaus woche will der kanzler werden
der mann der gerne mal als stumpf
dargestellt wird also schlug nikolaus
der neue kanzler bis dahin ist es noch
eine weile aber jetzt zur zeit sind alle
drei parteien mit dem was sie hier
errungen haben oder was sie sich
gegenseitig abgerungen haben und für
sich erreicht haben in ihren parteien
gremien parteigremien heißt im
parteivorstand und im präsidium bei der
fdp das sind digitale tagung bei der
beide cdu auch und ich nehme alles unter
den grünen ähnliches also jetzt
informiert man bevor die nation ist
erfährt bevor man vor die presse geht
werden die parteispitzen informiert die
kriegen jetzt im koalitionsvertrag und
die erfahrenen jetzt auch wer bei ihnen
wohl minister wird dann gar ein bild
-chef das ist nur in berlin all den
stunden der verhandlung während der
koalitionsvertrag da hinter den kulissen
jetzt ganz oft gedruckt und immer wieder
gedruckt wird damit alle ihnen in
deutschland tatsächlich auch lesen
können sie sofern nicht digitalisiert
danke peter und wir wollen reinholen in
die runde wolfgang bosbach cdu urgestein
mit der ersten reaktion werden paul noch
mal sein handy schickt wolfgang bosbach
herzlich willkommen bei bild live was
überwiegt heute bei ihnen gibt es bei
ihnen an diesem tag an dem hier im
politischen berlin so das gefühl
verbreitet werden soll von geschafft
jetzt partners an vermittelt sich ihnen
ein bisschen diese aufbruchstimmung oder
es ist einfach der schmerz zu tief
sitzen dass die union nicht dabei ist
das schöne grüße aus hamburg ist es
jetzt nicht anders als es 1998 war als
schröder fischer an die macht gekommen
sind und man wird sich gegenseitig logan
man wird sich auf die schulter klopfen
natürlich wird auch ein glas sekt
getrunken dann wird ein rhetorisches
feuerwerk abgebrannt tenor wird sein
jetzt wird alles neuer schöner besser
größer und am nächsten tag beginnt dann
der alltag und dann wird sich die
ampelkoalition an dem messen lassen was
sie verspricht was sie versprochen hat
und bin mit der redaktion bild
überrascht wie viel konkretes ist oder
die latte liegt wirklich hoch und dann
bin ich gespannt ob alles das eins zu
eins abgearbeitet wird was in dem
koalitionsvertrag an zusicherung gemacht
wurde und ich weiß papier ist geduldig
der politische alltag ist wesentlich
anstrengender nehmen sie nur ein
einziges beispiel 400.000 neue wohnungen
ja das kannst du schreiben du brauchst
aber auch fläche du brauchst investoren
du brauchst baurecht da bin ich mal
gespannt wie die koalition das alles
hinbekommen würden in kurzer zeit die
ziele sind also hoch gesteckt und
gleichzeitig hat dieser tag ja auch
schon erkenntnis darüber gebracht welche
posten an wen vergeben werden zumindest
ein paar sind schon bekannt gab es da
für sie überraschungen
nein im großen und ganzen war damit
zurecht in jedenfalls mit der
ressortverteilung und
das war doch von anfang an klar die fdp
kann überhaupt nicht auf das
finanzministerium verzichten soweit
erinnerlich hat christian lindner noch
nie regiert jetzt ist er zum ersten mal
in regierungsverantwortung hat ein ganz
ganz bedeutendes ministerium bekommen
und jetzt kann und jetzt muss er
beweisen dass er nicht nur ein
glänzender rhetoriker sondern auch ein
guter finanzminister ist dann wird aber
auch beim amtsantritt merken alleine
dadurch dass jetzt er statt olaf scholz
finanzminister geworden ist haben wir
keinen euro mehr in der kasse da sind ja
ein paar schillernde namen schon dabei
also habe ergeben wirtschaftsminister
christian lindner finanzminister anna
lena berger künftig außenministerin gibt
es irgendjemanden auf denen sie sich an
diesem ministeramt besonders freuen oder
gibt es jemanden über den sich freuen
dass das nicht geworden ist
also gespannt bin ich auf die
performance von annalena baerbock ich
mag sich ist etwas merkwürdig anhören
für einen cdu politiker dessen parteien
die opposition geschickt wurde aber als
bürger dieses landes wünsche ich mir
eine gute bundesregierung ich kann mir
gar nicht wünschen als staatsbürger dass
wir eine schlechte regierung haben oder
minister die im amt versagen aber ich
kann mir auch vorstellen so viel kritik
heiko maas in den letzten jahren
erfahren hat und nicht alle kritik war
grundlos vielleicht werden demnächst
einige sagen es waren doch kein guter
tausch anderen der burgstadt heiko maas
aber zunächst drücke ich allen
beteiligten die daumen und hoffe dass
sie in ihrem amt reduzieren er wusste wo
sehen sie das größte kraft potenzial in
dieser neuen regierung wie wird das
aussehen werden sich da christian
lindner und anton hofreiter
ja balken was glauben sie wie geht das
aus also zunächst glaube ich nicht dass
die grüne basis ist es scheint dann
lassen wird die haben so einen spaß am
regieren dass sie jetzt wieder
regieren können 2005 ist ja rot grün
gescheitert jetzt hat man wieder
möglichkeit nach 16 jahren
selbstverständlich wird die basis das
projekt nicht aufhalten dann wird es ein
bisschen kritik geben und am ende wird
es eine große mehrheit geben spannend
ist wenn die ampel koalition auf die
realität trifft wenn wir zu dem
kleingedruckten kommen wenn das was
jetzt in prosa niedergeschrieben wird in
gesetze sprache umgesetzt werden soll
ein kleines beispiel nur maxi flapsig
anhören ist aber nicht falsch mehrheit
hin mehrheit her gegen die physik wirst
du nicht gewinnen können beschallt
nächstes jahr die letzten kernkraftwerke
ab die letzten reihen die da noch am
netz sein werden haben im vergangenen
jahr so viel strom produziert wie die
hälfte aller windräder in deutschland ja
glaubt in irgendeiner ernsthaft dass wir
bis ende nächsten jahres 50 prozent mehr
windräder haben als wir sie jetzt schon
haben ich glaube daran nicht natürlich
hat man im ziel fest ausbau erneuerbarer
energien aber es muss doch alles
realistisch sein und wenn wir aus der
kohleverstromung aussteigen ist denn
sichergestellt dass wir bei dunkel
flaute weder kohlestrom noch atomstrom
aus dem ausland importieren müssen dass
wir eine grundlastfähigkeit alleine mit
erneuerbaren energien haben es wäre doch
ein witz des jahrhunderts wenn wir aus
kohle und atomstrom aussteigen und
anschließend aus kohle mine und
atomkraftwerken strom importieren müssen
wo die kraftwerke weniger leistungsfähig
in der region ihre wirkungskraft tragen
und ja du meiner nicht so sicher sind
wie bei uns herr bosbach ein wort noch
zu ihrer partei zu denjenigen die da
jetzt die autoschlüssel abgeben müssen
die keine sicherheit mehr haben die
ausziehen müssen aus den ministerien wie
sehr schmerzt dass wenn man sieht dass
man nicht mehr dabei ist also mit
einmalig ist sprechen können mit gerd
müller die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit der wahl in rom entspannt
und freut sich jetzt auf ein neues leben
anderer während es anders sehen ich habe
gestern noch mit einem staatssekretär
gesprochen also dann zum rednerpult ging
hat er gesagt märklin habe ich gesagt
kopf hoch leben geht weiter also es ist
immer wichtig dass die politik ein
wichtiger teil des lebens ist die
öffentliche verantwortung die wir haben
die ist wichtig aber wir selber sind es
doch nicht es gibt schon gute gründe
warum ich mich nicht
100% nie von der politik habe abhängig
machen lassen ich habe das immer sehr
sehr ernst genommen meine aufgaben aber
ich wollte nie nur politiker sein und
zur demokratie gehört auch der wechsel
damit muss man rechnen wir haben alle
nur verträge für vier jahre und das kann
sich immer wieder ändern jetzt gibt es
bestimmt einige die steigen jetzt nichts
wovon nur hinten rechts ein und sehen
dass der wagen nicht los fährt aber da
kann ich nicht helfen und man darf jetzt
auch nicht in trauer vorziehen das hat
man da lernen
das hat man dann relativ schnell kapiert
glaube ich allerdings dass nichts fährt
noch eine letzte frage was ist der tipp
was macht angela merkel in zukunft ich
weiß wir können alle nicht in die
glaskugel gucken sie wird ihnen
wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht verraten
haben aber was ist ihr tipp
ich glaube dass es zwei phasen geben
wird in der ersten phase wurde große
belastung abfällt wo sie immer die füße
hochlegt und die dinge pflegt zu denen
sie bis jetzt keine zeit hatte sie ist
ja eine liebhaberin zum beispiel wird
klassische musik also das gönne ich ihr
auch und dann wird sie merken oder fehlt
mir aber doch einiges ich bin ganz
sicher sie wird sich nicht in die
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit über die
dienste von irgendwelchen russischen
gaskonzern begeben die wird also gerne
plans folgen aber da sie international
eine rolle spielen wird oder sozial
karitatives engagement zeigt für
projekte die ihr wichtig sind das glaube
ich schon sie ist ein homo politicus und
ohne politik geht es bei ihr liegt und
bei mir auch nicht wolfgang bosbach
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch